Souvent on nous reproche de faire
excessivement de Bruxelles 1 bouc émissaire.
Alors bien sûr,
l'Europe n'a pas
directement effondré l'autorité dans le pays,
fabriqué la pénurie de médecin où fait chuter le
niveau scolaire.
Cela, c'est la France de Macron
qui l'a réussi toute seule comme 1 grande.
Mais l'Union européenne ne se contente pas de nous
empêcher de résoudre nos problèmes,
elle les aggrave et parfois même elle en invente.
On pourrait citer
le marché
européen de l'électricité
qui rechirait artificiellement
aux factures d'énergie,
de la réforme des retraites
imposées par la commission ou encore du pacte vert
et de l'écologie punitive que Marine a évoqué
qui fragilise en ce moment même nos agriculteurs.